my name is Carol beau gash I am a
director of educational and cultural
programs for the Smithsonian associates
and I'm delighted that you here this
evening at the Smithsonian castle
sitting in the library which seems like
a perfect place for this program we are
here to celebrate and enjoy the art of
biography this evening highlights the
first in a new series by HarperCollins
Publishers titled imminent lives in
which a number of distinguished authors
will publish biographies of well-known
figures central to history and culture I
want to thank all of you are members of
the resident associate program for your
membership and for coming out for
programs like this one tonight and for
all of those who are not members of this
resident associate program we hope that
you'll join us to discuss the art of
biography tonight we are delighted to
have Christopher Hitchens Francine prose
and Michael kurta as our guests their
discussion is moderated by Marc Pachter
the director of the National Portrait
Gallery and editor of telling lives the
biographers art Christopher Hitchens is
the author of more than 10 books
including recently a long short war the
postponed liberation of Iraq he
contributes a monthly essay on books to
the Atlantic Monthly which I go to first
when my magazine arrives and is a
contributing editor to Vanity Fair he is
also the author of the forthcoming
biography of Thomas Jefferson can't wait
for that Francine prose is the author of
a dozen novels among them Bigfoot dreams
and household saints the most recent
work was the lives of the muses nine
women and the artists they inspired in
addition to a new novel to be published
in March titled
a changed man her forthcoming biography
for the eminent live series is on
Caravaggio can't wait for that either
Michel kurta is a writer of both fiction
and nonfiction
including another life a memoir of other
people charmed lives and the Immortals
is also editor-in-chief and corporate
vice president of Simon & Schuster his
book for the eminent live series is
ulysses s grant which is available for
sale and signing this evening they can't
wait to get that the series on eminent
lies edited by James Atlas mr. atlas
was a staff writer for Time and
assistant editor for the New York Times
Book Review and the New York Times
magazine as well as contributing editor
to the Atlantic in New Yorker and Vanity
Fair mr. Atlas is the founder of Atlas
books and the author of several
biographies including Delmore Schwartz
the life of an American poet and bellow
a biography we have a stellar group of
speakers for you this evening so we're
delighted that you could be here and
that they're here and would you please
join me in giving a warm Smithsonian
welcome to James Atlas
I'm actually very distracted by these
pandas over here I don't know how many
of you can see them chewing and running
around but I hope they're not a reproach
to our Talk's tonight I'm very glad to
have this team of biographers here I
like to think of them as my team I'm
sure better behaved and the Pistons and
the Pacers and I'm sometimes asked how I
got the idea of publishing series of
short biographies this is the sequel to
the penguin lives that I founded a few
years ago and I don't want to be in a
succession of speakers here but very
briefly I was on page a thousand of my
own biography of Saul Bellow
which had grown as tall as my children
developing at the same rate and when I
got to page a thousand which I laminated
and gave to my editor at Random House as
a present she looked rather alarmed and
I thought there must be some other way
to do this so at that moment the idea
flew into my head that there should be
short books by distinguished writers a
tradition that's long flourished in
English and American letters from
Aubrey's brief five through Johnson's
lives of the poets and Lytton Strachey
in many different forms so what we have
here in these brief lives is really a
revival of a venerable form done by very
lively and distinguished writers who are
not specialists in their field that's
what I think the dynamic that's so
exciting about it to have novelists
journalists historians writing about
biography and as a practitioner as a
practicing biographer for the last
thirty years you command I have a very
long shelf of biographies myself and
books about biography more than a
five-foot shelf and three of them that
are the most prominent that I refer to
time and again
Leon needles essays on literary
biography richard almonds golden codgers
i had the great good fortune to be a
student of almonds at Oxford at which
I'm sure sent me on my own path and
marked actors telling lives it's mark
has been at the Smithsonian he tells me
for as long as I've been preoccupied
with biography I don't know if I should
say how long that is but thirty years
and he's the director of the National
Portrait Gallery and an old friend of
the biographers art telling wives is a
terrific book that features seven
writers thinking about biography writing
about biography it came out in 1979 and
includes Doris Kearns and Justin Caplan
and Geoffrey Wolfe but I also am great
fan of Marc's introduction in which he
really crystallizes in just 12 or 13
pages what it means to write a biography
and he really understands all the
elements of at the biographers
ambivalence towards his subject the way
he becomes obsessed with his pursuit the
struggle to maintain a balance between
narrative and interpretation it's all
there and I can always tell from his
citations that he's read as deeply as
anyone has in the field I can always
crib from his introduction to find the
quote from Plutarch and Boswell and
Johnson that I need it was interesting
when I pulled the volume down from the
Shelf this morning to look at again I
was looking at the title instead telling
lives and reminded me of something that
WH Auden once said that only an S
separates the word cosmic from the word
comic so they looked at inside that well
actually only a V separates telling
lives from telling lies and I can assure
you that mark is on the right side if
you have any doubt I'll read you a
sentence from his introduction his
search for the truth and a wife is the
biographers preeminence day
and his own response to that truth
shapes his art and I think that's as
good a credo as any so when I learned
that mark would be presiding over this
evening I knew that we were all in good
hands and I'm glad to welcome Marc
Pachter thanks very much
we'll put that way I'm a hard act to
follow so I won't say very much because
we really want to get to the proceedings
tonight I suppose I might say only one
thing and it's really about the National
Portrait Gallery those of you who don't
know it and we've been closed in our
building in Washington for a number of
years now we reopen in July 4th Oh 6 you
might think well what is an art
historian doing fascinated by biography
and I would simply say this to situate
myself in this inquiry that the National
Portrait Gallery is not principally
about portraiture understood as a visual
art it is a national institution of
biography it is really a place of
portrayal and so when I got there
initially I immediately wanted to
establish that fact in a broader sense
by having the discussions which led to
telling lives and of course the pun was
intent in tensional are the the possible
pun when I did that because I wanted
people to understand biographers as
portrays or portraitists and I find and
it's my segue into the evening where I
will invite the panelists to come up
that a lot of the language to describe
modern biography is borrowed from
portraiture when it wants to be 6 inked
and artful and that certainly is the
match we're looking for words like a
profile sometimes biographers actually
say they are doing a portrait of an
individual and every time that happens
you you you have the sense that the the
notion of just the heat of fact that
might be biography and was it heavily in
the 19th century becomes sculpted into a
particular life told by a particular
voice and that's really I think the kind
of biography that James Atlas is
inviting us to enjoy through this
remarkable series that being said I
would like to invite the panelists to
come up here and
as you see so shall you begin
what I have set as the rhythm of the
evening if I hope to suits all of you is
an opportunity to see a number of things
one I think we want our own individual
glimpse in the words of the biographers
of the perhaps it's the marriage they
struck with the subject in this series
or their approach to biography so I've
asked them to each speak for about five
minutes on on that match that they've
made then after that I will ask a number
of questions too to invite conversation
and we will certainly leave some time at
the end for your questions as well so
that will be the rhythm of the evening
that being said Michael would you like
to give us your free
I was a voracious reader of biography on
the time I was 12 living if I did in
England and going to school in
Switzerland the American Civil War was
not something that loomed large in my
education in England we had our own
civil war a good many centuries before
yours and in Switzerland so far as I
know there has never been one but my
father kept books everywhere and never
cared what you read he had no interest
in preventing you from reading anything
or encouraging I came across the works
of whose captain now somewhat
disregarded as an American story and
thought to be too popular and found
myself plunging into the Civil War and
came away from it with a tremendous and
password fascination with the figure of
robber to me that is a fascination
shared by more people than not Lee is
still an enormous Lee iconic figure and
an enormous Lee admired figure and it
took me two or three years of reading
into the Civil War before it occurred to
me that Lee had been beaten by Grant
also that Lee like Rama was a bad
general a good general rather in a bad
cause because no matter how you cut it
the cause was rebellion and slavery in
disunion whereas grant was a good
general in a good cause and so I got
interested more and more interested in
Grant whose awkwardness whose shyness
whose ferocity in battle whose skill at
handling large numbers of men seemed to
me extraordinary and also seemed to me
to have received not sufficient respect
when the great presidents are toted up
there's always a caller in magazines for
the bad presidents
and grant always appears either below or
above Harding I did not feel he belonged
there and early in coming to grips with
the question of who grant this elusive
and shy figure who is by any standards
the greatest general America has ever
produced and by any rational standards a
significant important and excellent
President Grant himself defined what
made me write his life in his own
writing for he is also of all presidents
and certainly of all generals the best
writer and his book is one of the few
non-fiction books that is a piece and a
part of American literature he wrote I
read but few lives of great men because
biographers do not as a rule tell us
enough about the formative period of
life what I want to know is what a man
did as a boy and I decided that's what I
want to know about grant I wanted to
know the boy who became the victor of
Shiloh the victor of Fort Donelson I
wanted to know the grant who acquired a
reputation as a drunk but still became a
successful general and a president I
wanted to know who that boy was and to
show readers who he was and how he
became what he became and that I think
is if not the art of biography at any
rate the thing that pushes most of us
into writing them we will perhaps come
back to that subject as a broadly but
before we go on and I'm in effect asking
this of each of you and never occurred
to me to ask before we began in this
particular series were you invited into
the series and asked to choose a life or
did the editor may have been the great
mr. analysts himself did he say to you
I've always been interested
in kurta so was it was it your choice to
pick grant or were you given an idea I
must confess that gym necklaces charm
and power persuasion as such that's said
I cannot remember the exact sequence of
that that led to it I had he had asked
me to write a biography and I had
proposed a number of people who
interested me but did not seem to have
the right kind of eminence for him and
after a couple of tries I had wanted to
do Ike a lesser general no I would plan
for most honest as an equal of grants I
had been tempted to do a biography of
Hitler because I don't think there is a
good short one fortunately for me Jim
talked me out of that and I proposed
grant which he loved and I'm very happy
because I loved the euro more that I
spent with grant and I would have hated
the euro more than I would have had to
have spent with Hitler I think that's
that's interesting to know Francine how
did you come to this project first
really through Caravaggio's work there
was a great Caravaggio show in New York
in 1985 at the Met and I remember going
to it I mean I'd seen Caravaggio's
paintings in reproduction before but
there's practically no one who
reproduces so badly as Caravaggio I saw
the show and he became really one of the
most important painters to me so I began
so when I would travel I would make sure
that I would find the museum's that had
Caravaggio's and and go to them and I
began to notice a sort of a thing that
interested me which is that even in
museums that were under populated and
empty there'd be a huge crowd in front
of the Caravaggio painting there was
always a big [ __ ] and then I began to
things began to happen for example I
went to Rome a couple of years ago I was
just beginning to think about doing
Caravaggio and we arrived there very
early in the morning we had jetlag we
didn't feel like going to sleep so we
went down we were staying up on the gene
Janicki Lemoine we went down to look at
the
great Caravaggio's in the in the church
of san Louie
Luigi franchisee and I noticed the guy
there who I'd seen on the plane and he'd
been on the same plane with us they'd
come over at the same time and and he
had come straight off the plane as we
had to see the Caravaggio's and I
thought no he must be an artist or an
art critic and I said what are you doing
what do you do and he said well I'm an
accountant for Mayor Bloomberg's office
right but he had that same passion and
in the course of working on the book I
found all sorts of people in unexpected
walks of life that had that feeling for
care about you I knew a few things about
Caravaggio's life and I knew I mean I'm
a novelist really I'm not a biographer I
knew that his life was a novelist dream
it was a very I started thinking about
it when it was still the brief live
series and his was a really brief life
he'd lived to be 39 his life was
extremely dramatic he was accused and
probably committed a murder he was on
the run from the police and various
other groups of people for the last four
years of his life and he was the
original bad boy Renaissance artist so
so between the love for the work and the
drama of the life it seemed like a
natural project and mr. atlas saw that
immediately when you proposed it
well mr. heartless and I have known each
other for about thirty years now so so
we would see each other we would see
each other at parties and so forth and
talk about the possibility of my doing
something and I knew that I wanted to do
a visual artist I'd begun writing art
criticism for The Wall Street Journal so
it was I'd wanted and also I wanted to
write about paintings and we talked
about a few artists and then I guess I
came up with Caravaggio and I ran into
Jim and he said oh just that day someone
had have been in a meeting saying we
should get someone to do Caravaggio so
that's how it worked out faked
thank Lully Christopher I've just
realized it's a Hogwarts dining room
that we're in I knew I knew it would
come to me in a second ahead with with
pandas and hard by Jefferson Street no
this one here is Jefferson way I think
yes yeah there are three there are now I
realize there are three Rosel streets in
Washington DC named for Jefferson I
think he's the only one of whom that can
be said and it's probably just as well
because I now know there were at least
three of him but it's it's it's telling
that there should be as many as that I
was always no other resistant to the
idea of biography I had done a couple of
stretchy type debunking zuv people I
thought were overrated but you're not
really doing your job as a cultural
critic in a celebrity culture if you
don't do some of that stretchy type work
there are so many great tethered blimps
just waiting for your attention but I
hadn't wanted to push it any further I
think this came out of a probably some
residual Marxism on my part it was the
feeling that the in the telling of
history the the role of the great man or
great woman the individual is overrated
at the expense of discussion of ideas or
forces when I was in England it was
released for the early years of it it
was a pageant of monarchs we periodized
our history by reins
I don't think we stop theorizing by
reins actually until probably the 30s
and then suddenly if you notice history
is no longer pure dies that way we still
do it by administration sometimes by
administrations or sometimes by decades
as well America I think probably
contributes a great deal to that that
form of periodization at any rate these
were the resistances I had to overcome
and then maybe some possibly some false
modesty - in other words it seems not
Cystic to be writing in this way and I
didn't envy the life of people like
Michael Holroyd for the opposite reason
that seemed to be to self effacing you
were associated journey with someone
else's life what are you going to do to
have one of your own if you have to live
the life of your subject all the time so
that that was my frame and state of mind
when mr. atlas
Luo man approached me and said what I
like to do Margret Thatcher and I
thought I said yes it didn't treat me as
an idea and I don't know how he knew
this but a few weeks later he called a
cell you know I I don't think you're
really happy with that are you and I
realized I hadn't been thinking about it
in the bath
exactly or in the shower just
unfailingly good sign for me when I have
my first cigarette under a shower in the
morning see if I'm still concentrating
or not
and I said nose mother Frank no and the
only other time I'd ever been asked to
do about considerable fee was by an
agent who I think thought well if he
would give me a position in society of
some kind and it proposed Albert
Einstein and I I knew at the first
shower that that was wrong because
Hitchens on Einstein it just doesn't
compute if I thought it was ridiculous I
was fairly sure everybody else would so
then he said well what about Jefferson
and I realized in that instant that not
only had I always wanted to write about
Thomas Jefferson but that a lot of the
time I was doing so in any case because
anyone who makes America their subject
is is in a sense condemned maybe that's
too bleak a word but it's the de-rate
destined to write I think about Thomas
Jefferson part of the time and all
political conversation to some extent
involves him and while I live in a city
that's partly his memorial I've lived
here for nearly a quarter of a century
I now know we have the same birthday
that he was born in under the old
calendar had to change his birthday
during the course of his life we share
with Seamus Heaney and Orlando Letelier
among others and then I realized that
James had wanted this terse biography
and I thought how wonderful that would
be I forget of what book it is that dr.
Johnson says no man could possibly wish
it longer it may be given but but that
with Jefferson I wished he'd asked me to
take a little more space and if ever
even asked him if I might go to the
upper limit and perhaps a fraction
beyond for this reason Jefferson is in
power more or less continuously once he
goes to administer in in Paris for 25
years very nearly a solid quarter of a
century at the top of the political tree
and that is after he has written the
Declaration of Independence and been the
governor of Virginia and composed the
Virginia statute of religious freedom so
it's an extraordinary life in in every
way and it's a very very massive one and
he kept an enormous correspondence going
and he wrote it a number of journals and
was and I don't think now it would
possible for any one person to say that
they had read everything everything by
him and about him I think it might be
beyond the compass of an individual to
have done that but it's worth it it's
worth a try and it's it's a huge it's a
huge education in what is already the
great subject that's the United States
I know I've spoken fractionally too long
already but I'll trust us a little more
if I if I may the the project of the
Enlightenment which was part of his
design and part of his declaration was
what influenced him the most it comes
out all the time not just in the
substituting happiness for property in
the declaration but also in the
paradoxes of his attitude to his own
property and in his wanting to be
remembered only he designed as you may
know his own memorial and it's the one
that is at Charlottesville and he wanted
to be remembered only for the authorship
of the Declaration the authorship of the
Virginia statute on religious freedom
and the founding of the University of
Virginia that's what he wanted okay
never mention been president twice and
vice president and secretary of state
and governor and minister wasn't he
thought that much worthy of notice in
even when he designed the Lewis and
Clark expedition and to some extent even
the Louisiana Purchase he was thinking
of nation-building certainly but he was
thinking of building a new kind of
nation that was based on a secular and
scientific approach to life and humanity
and one of the things that interests me
most is his utter contempt for all forms
of religious faith which is of a
contempt that I personally share and
that's probably never been more germane
than at the present of the idea of
whether United States is or is not a
secular country no other problem is too
many for runners I mean the Dumas Malone
biography which is the quarry from which
the truck still Rumble away with chunks
of terms in my book I actually say I
wish I could do to it while Jefferson
did to the Bible namely take a braise
the blade and cut out all the
superfluous junk and say the Malone book
is in a way a disgrace and someone needs
to do mr. Farr outdo me and do a replay
Merrill Peterson's
rivalries worth mentioning I think here
very good shorter but solid book and
then just because everybody asks about
Sally I've never met anyone and told
them about the project who hasn't asked
me about this I should simply say that I
do not see why there's ever been any
controversy about this at all
I do not see how anyone could look at
that evidence and being the smallest
doubt the Jefferson was the father of
those children long before the DNA tests
were made long before even Annette
Gordon reads brilliant book it's staring
you in the face and so it was
fascinating for me to find that many
people vastly senior to myself and much
more qualified could have examined that
evidence and either concluded that it
didn't point in that way all that it was
it was ambivalent and so I've done a
chapter just on that I'm as I thought I
had to do sorry ladies and gentlemen but
my subject just lived a lot longer and I
think the point of being consumed by the
subject is exactly exactly appropriate
one thing our Jefferson and then a
general question and that is that it's
not only the name of the streets that
are after Jefferson but there are at
least there are three I think only but
particularly domes that are precisely
meant to evoke Monticello the Natural
History Museum in the the old of West
Wing of the Art Museum the National
Gallery and then actually whether it was
intentional or not it speaks to the
other to the new National Museum of the
American Indian they're all in effect
tributes to the Jeffersonian ideal
he even has a form of democracy named
after him which doesn't come to
everybody yes well now the broader
question which takes off from each of
your characterizations of your passion
I'll start with an anecdote which would
add to this point and that is that I I
was I had the interesting experience of
being with David McCullough the day
after he had told his publisher to take
back to the million dollar advance he
had gotten to write Picasso and and he
had tried a heart for a year
writing Picasso and decided he just
couldn't do it and I think it was a
matter not of expertise in his point of
view although he was the first to admit
he wasn't an expert on art it was a
matter of sympathy and the that
brilliant publisher of his said instead
of accepting the million back whom would
you like to write about and he said
Harry Truman and that led to it so I the
question I want to ask you is the
question of sympathy I think we felt
some of it in your descriptions of your
subjects but have you found it necessary
to feel sympathetic towards your subject
we have this Strachey notion of sort of
taking your subject on but have you
found it important to have a feeling
that this is a life that you can evoke
and admire or is admiration not critical
to your telling of the story I'm first
like to say that having been David
McCullough's editor for we're doing five
years or so yes that this is this is an
anecdote oh it's like a mouthful I am
the poet it's true yes good and and and
that leads me to say something which I
feel but which I've never properly
analyzed the art of biography would be
limiting if we limited it only to those
subjects whom we liked or felt we would
be comfortable with Hitler is a perfect
example of somebody with whom most of us
would certainly feel uncomfortable but
in many ways ought to be studied very
carefully and there's a deficiency as a
matter of fact in the English language
of really good biographies of Hitler
whereas a really good one would be a
valuable and important book so I think
that we can't limit biography or think
about biography as if it were a form of
fan mail
I would have been very uncomfortable
writing a biography of of Lee much as I
admire him because there's something
remote and something altogether cold
about Lee a perfection of manner which
which seems off-putting or at any rate
which seems off-putting to us at present
whereas I found with grant that his very
shabby nurse and his bouts of
drunkenness and his self-doubt and his
awkwardness and his unhappy childhood
made him a figure that I related to and
could feel a great sympathy for so I
think that the biographer really has to
decide whether you were going to be a
full-time professional writer
in which case as was the case with
Harold Nicolson when the call comes from
Buckingham Palace to honor you with the
task of writing the definitive official
biography of George v you say yes and
accept the fact that it will be five
years of working you'll get a knighthood
afterwards and that's perfectly
respectable but for the amateur
biography biographer I feel that the
task would be impossible if you didn't
like your subject Francine you spoke of
a fascination with this life and
certainly an admiration for the orphan
but not necessarily a sympathy
well carriage is the last guy you'd want
to meet in a dark alley somewhere I mean
he was a brawler you know he was in
trouble with the law over 20 times
during his life he was well he was a
murderer actually and but I found him
incredibly appealing and romantic and
attractive I mean for one thing he was a
genius which is always attractive
for another he was himself was
passionate about art I mean he you know
he left no writings so we don't in fact
there's very little information about
his life he left he didn't write a word
that we know about but there's one there
was a court case he was involved in he
was and he was sued for libel by a
fellow painter and he was
terrible to his fellow painters I mean
critical and insulting and there's the
document of the court case in which he
gives this incredibly beautiful
impassioned defense of real art of art
that's drawn from nature of art that
that is not idealized and you know when
you when I was started learning about
his life I realized how near the end of
his life or just before the murder
actually he'd been extremely successful
and celebrated painter in Rome and then
the more sentimental the more saccharine
the more acceptable artist began to be
more popular and he just went kind of
crazy as a result well all those things
how could I possibly not be sympathetic
to this guy and that's important in your
choice you think of a life to live with
in this way I would have wanted to write
about him had he been you know a mass
murderer I mean I don't think that would
have affected my decision the art would
still would have been the art but but I
did find him hugely appealing
Christopher I want to ask the same
question of you but to say one thing I
once interviewed Duma Malone who had
spent those almost fifty years and five
volumes of Jefferson and I asked him a
question that I would like to ask you
although his take was probably different
from yours i said the jefferson ever
disappoint you and he paused because of
his project was a project of monumental
admiration and he did give some
instances when jefferson disappointed
him but he was a bit taken aback so I'm
gonna ask you does this sort of soup of
admiration apply to how you think about
Jefferson and if so did he this
disappoint you well for me it was above
all necessary that he be the subject of
a continuous argument you know it's that
he not be a figure on whom there's a
general agreement or ever will be
because then I knew I would never get
bored so that I wouldn't feel the rattle
of the revolver against my teeth in the
morning because what you don't want when
you're writing a book and you'll
guaranteed that with Jefferson but
though of course you are a to some
extent you are writing counter to
hagiographical portrayal I mean
obviously I should
save Malone that he's like it's not
Klaus and Weems exactly but he clearly
felt he had a responsibility for
representing this part of American
history in a you know respectable way to
borrow well there was that Georgia v yes
I think I have to call a respectable
we're mustn't upset the schoolchildren
too much there's certain things that and
I don't know which instances he gave to
come to your second part of your
question well before I do that there's
another thing I think it's it's it's a
jolly good thing if you're writing about
somebody where there are no tapes no
photographs nothing of this kind where
it's literature Manette the written word
will remain and you have to go and look
at the stuff and it's all reading there
are some good portraits of him it would
have cost be lovely to have a photograph
but no one really knows and there are
lots of a bearers of himself that he
kept very private
I think Gore Vidal's description of him
in burr is very plausible that he was a
very passionate person but very very
much under control and with a splinter
of ice somewhere in his core and if you
ask the question that I was asked about
anyone I know it's just if they were an
animal what kind what animal would they
be he would be a fairly large Fox with a
questioning muzzle and a ruthless
disposition and a good deal of honey I
think you admire foxes I'm not against
you can't eat them worst a
disappointment therefore I don't know
what Malone's replies to you were by the
way but I mean what I really have
against Malone it's in my book actually
is it at one point he said of the claims
by the Hemings descendants that they
were they had Jefferson's blood he said
well that's just what you'd expect you
know they're just trying to make
themselves more more pedigreed he said
it's just like what some farmers and
stock breeders do cunning Showtime or
race time they play pretend preposterous
lineages for their animals
well I thought that's a bit much as a
comparison for one thing what what did
he think he was saying there and for a
second you know it's rather the other
way around in point of who owns whom
this this blood stock the analogy and I
thought gosh but it seemed no why else
cared about that that was a consider a
respectable reply at the time well they
Yvette I of course knew as anyone who
goes to the Jefferson Memorial can see
that a lot of editing of his stuff is
required to make it in sizeable in
laboratory form on that memorial that
nothing is more certainly written in the
book of fate than that these people
shall be free you have to cut out a lot
of what he elsewhere said and of course
everybody knew there was a paradox in
his life but I guess I was shocked to
find out how much and how coldly he was
determined not just to postpone the
abolition of slavery but to extend the
time in which it would be an institution
I didn't I don't think I appreciated at
all the extent to which that was true
and I think disappointment isn't quite
the right word for that is it but it's a
it was an education anyway find that yes
no it's very much to the point
Malone's disappointment was the extent
to which having great so many of his
letters how much as Malone said he
massaged the truth yes and then he went
on to excuse that as the southern
disposition but yeah well it won't be
about Malone has an answer for
everything actually there is another big
disappointment both Jefferson and his
wife thought tristram shandy was a very
funny book so you're dealing with people
who had no sense of humor they were
sitting around and read it to each other
in the long evening so it's a real run
for life image I think that not not a
chuckle a minute
the next question is again I think
perhaps inevitable in this series that
we're contemplating and that is the
question of brevity as a virtue I think
James actually suggested maybe I didn't
hear it while I was just basking in the
glory of what it was saying about me but
I think he did suggest something about
it being more comfortable to do a short
life
you're not actually an expert on the
life which I think we would mean I there
is a professional biographer or not
necessarily that but somebody who wasn't
immersed before in the life but I wonder
if that's the only issue in brevity
strachey who's the the father of us all
in terms of some of these aspirations
really felt that brevity was critical to
the capturing of a life and that he felt
that anything else those long volumes
where it was a kind of entombment and
that the life was only really
presentable and EVO Keable briefly now
that being said that was straight cheap
but Michael what about what about the
the sort of the length of either time
invested in the project and in the form
itself do you think it suits but to
answer it you know I I wrote a biography
of my father and his two brothers called
charmed lives which was a very long book
I felt like WC Fields comes I've been
good I've been rich and I've been poor
and believe me rich is better there's a
pleasure to riding along biography you
can play with the materials you would
put them in you could deal with people's
correspondence you can sum up long lives
you have more room to play with and that
was for me a great experience and and if
somebody had said to me you couldn't
write a biography of grant but he can't
be less than say 700 manuscript pages
that would not have daunted me at all in
fact I think I would have been somebody
energized by that and done it happily I
think it's in some ways more difficult
to condense a life into a short form and
indeed I think one of the challenges
that Jim Atlas presents his authors with
is not just to write about somebody who
interests them which is kind of a form
of state put up or shut up if you're
that interesting do it which is very
smart but
the other is to say it must be of this
particular small length so that you have
to condense you have to get the whole
story into a very small number
Russell sonnet yeah I think that's a
most interesting challenge if you take
grant for example to me if anything
truly astonished me and pleased me it
was my ability or so I fancy to make
grants campaigns and battles crystal
clear to a nun military reader in the
very short form and without maps and if
I had to put my hand to anything and say
I'm amazed I could do that that is the
thing that amazes me the most so I think
it is a challenge certainly the bigger
the life the harder it is to get into
160 book pages but it's a fascinating
challenge it is what makes writing these
biographies such an acute pleasure is
that it's different from anything else
we do as a writer other books by and
large we go on and on and on and on
until we feel we finally run the subject
to death you can't do that with a book
distich running the subject to death is
a rather nice description for biography
but yes Francine when Jim posed this not
only as a topic well you you had the
topic but but as a length was that
daunting or was that exactly what what
you had hoped well I was in a very
different situation than Michael and
Christopher because if I were to write
down everything that was known and had
been everything that was known for a
fact about Caravaggio's life the book
would have been about 15 pages long so
then the question is what else I wanted
to put in the book besides Caravaggio's
life I mean certain things seemed
important to me that is what Rome was
like during the time in which he lived
what the social and political climate
during the different paper seas were was
and you know contemporary art history I
mean there was a very very good
biography of Caravaggio published about
ten years ago by Helen Langdon and in
some ways I didn't have much to add to
that but what I did have so in its own
way being able to concentrate it and
compress it was was was great for me but
also I knew that I wanted to be able to
write about the paintings in a way that
hadn't that they hadn't been written
about so I could take everything about
the life a certain amount about the
about the surrounding history and then
just write as much as I wanted about the
paintings which was ideal for me mm-hmm
Christopher decides obviously the
hardest person of all would be would be
William Shakespeare so all books about
him have to be Shakespeare and his time
or some various orders we know
practically nothing and at this length
too he's to go to a medium length I mean
you could do a little anyway well as
I've said already I shouldn't leave as a
point but with my subject quite large
books or series of books have been
written about just the Louisiana
Purchase or the Lewis and Clark
expedition or the Barbary war as it's
commonly called that actually very
little part of Jefferson's life the
decision to go to war with the Islamic
tyrannies of North Africa so I was
spoiled for choice as far as all that
went
what one tries to do I think is to find
something that's vaguely thematic in
other words well here's the here is the
same story but it's in a different form
the same things are operating on
Jefferson when he's doing apparently
quite discrepant policy and so by doing
that you can fold it in a bit I think I
hope I've managed to do that and then I
can share a corny theme with you if you
like well sure
well the fourth of July generally agreed
to be the data from era independence it
probably isn't but it's the one that
they decided they hid apart to agree oh
that was the day of the Declaration and
it is also the day on which the
Louisiana Purchase is announced in the
public
in Washington which is also the day that
Lewis and Clark say goodbye to their
master and leave for Pittsburgh to set
off for the West and it's also the day
on which Jefferson dies on the same day
as John Adams so there are there are
ways again we're still hanging out of a
line and draping worse things along it
to give it some shape and also by the
way you're gonna need this line because
you have to have the thread of Ariadne
in the labyrinth and something to follow
and hold on to yourself the the three
themes I'm really referring back to what
Michael said about the childhood and the
becoming the subject of becoming the
individual and how each of you balance
these elements that's really also speaks
to what Christopher just said once
Edmund Morris said to me that what he
and he who did not write a short
biography is still is still writing the
biography of he could but he hasn't done
in fact he thought originally was just
going to be a screenplay as you know but
well edmund morris is a passionate
pianist so he but he would have loved
that but but in the Theodore Roosevelt
basically he's given the arc broadly and
then devoted a separate book you know
the sweetness of youth as he would put
it the rise of Theodore Roosevelt the
period of power Theodore Rex which we've
seen and then the one he really wants to
write about which is the decline that's
the Greek arc that he's interested in in
your books have you waited it toward any
one of these periods in the life
childhood period of sort of consummate
achievement and then decline Caravaggio
didn't have time for decline but but to
start with Michael is it really heavily
weighted toward the young grant I would
say yes
but I would do the same for almost
anybody I think that without exploring
in depth somebody's childhood you're
leaving out the most interesting part
and the part that that enables the rest
of the life to make sense once you know
the child then very often the other
person becomes much more knowable unless
you know about the child the more in
doubt you are about knowing the adult
with Grant the childhood is of enormous
interest in an enormous importance and
I've devoted probably more pages than I
should have to it partly because I
wanted to write about what a childhood
in Ohio and Illinois was like in the
1820s and 1830s I think it's extremely
important in writing biography to bear
in mind which for some reason
biographers have great difficulty in
doing as a rule that we are writing
about people who aren't living today
therefore we first of all oh the reader
to wreak the the recreation of their
lives
within the society and the kind of world
in which they lived we also owe them not
judging people and events by the
standards that apply today because if
you were writing about seventy in the
1830s you must write about them within
the standards that applied in the 1830s
not in 2004 I would say with the bulk of
grant nevertheless has got to be if
you're writing a biography about him his
genius as a general and the the the
threads of life of childhood of early
experience of West Point that in this
singularly on promising young man who
had the lowest marks ever recorded in
the history of West Point at that time
accepted horsemanship and was also the
worst-dressed and most slovenly dressed
cadet in the history of West Point to go
back knowing what we know now and take
out of it the threads that you see will
one day produce this extraordinary
ability to command men in battle and
this enormous courage that grant to
spread himself as a soldier that is a
fascinating task so yes I think the
answer is that you must in writing
biography devote a substantial amount of
text to the thing that the person is
famous for and best at it would just be
self-indulgent to produce a book that
was 3/4 childhood and only one-quarter
accomplishment some books are only that
but not not your book and not if you're
writing the whole life and also I think
I've since now one bond of sympathy
that's the horsemanship yeah it would be
another connection between you and yes I
have to admit that that I am a horseman
myself and I love horses and always have
and that one of the things that is
always attracted me to grant was that at
the age of 10 or 11 he was a self-taught
horse whisperer and people brought him
farm horses from all or hyuah in
Illinois that were intractable that
bolted the kick to that couldn't be
ridden and this 10 or 11 year old boy
without knowing how he did could gentle
them whisper to them and hand them back
to their owners cured and and if that
has been an attractive trade in a man
who was later argued to come in general
I don't know what is I think we
discovered the real reason why you wrote
that book Francine in the short life of
Caravaggio do you look at this as the
sort of segments of growth and well you
know I decided to begin the book with
the end of Caravaggio's life with the
last four years of his life the murder
was committed in 60 and
and he in Rome and he'd left Rome he
fled to the hills outside Rome then he
fled from Rome to Naples he was doing
okay in Naples he was getting
commissions he fled Naples for some
unknown reason he went to Malta he
became a knight of Malta which was very
unusual he got into trouble he was
imprisoned he escaped from prison he
fled Malta he went to Sicily went to
Syracuse
he got a commission he painted one of
his most beautiful paintings he fled
Syracuse he went to Messina who was
accused by a schoolteacher of looking
oddly at some of the school boys at play
he fled got he hit the guy flibben
sobered sort went back to Naples died
under mysterious circumstances going to
Rome
the astonishing thing to me about that
period in his life was that he continued
to paint he was never anywhere for more
than a few months
he continued to get commissions and he
did so the most extraordinary moving
gorgeous paintings of his career so it
seemed to me that those years
concentrated everything that was most
violent turbulent and mysterious about
his life so that's where I started and
then I moved back to the beginning from
there and the arc of Jefferson's life is
you
in 80 I mentioned the parson Weems
schoolers with sentimental hagiography
before most of those which I think have
their origins in myth and in religion do
stress you know extraordinary things
about the childhood like George
Washington and the cherry tree which we
know to be false as is the story of Kim
Jong Il's birth being attended by
showers of bluebirds that spoke Korean
as is all the stuff that we're about to
have to go through celebrating again
next month or Bulls from beginning to
end
and I'm very glad that there's almost
none of that in Jefferson to be quarried
from as far as Kent know it I mean I
haven't been as lucky perhaps in my
subjects as but I mean it's the bit in
most public fees that I find most
irritating and in Jefferson's case we
know his own choreography doesn't really
mention his childhood at all
he says somewhere else it's in a letter
his first memory is where this family's
moving house and he was carried on a
cushion by a slave who's named he knew
or Layton you knew which David had been
little boy lying on a cushion being
Canada of course his life ends on a
deathbed surrounded by unpaid domestic
labor we know but we don't know why he
did not like his mother at all and
obviously that for most bugger offers
would be something far too good to miss
I mean we know that that has to be
important it's very rare and it must be
suggestive they didn't like mama avoided
all mention her for when possible didn't
give a damn when she died
can't think of anyone else except gore
Vidal who could say that yeah quite
respected his father clearly was very
lucky for him his life begins with his
education which is very good because he
is a man of the Enlightenment and of
great learning and of and he's one of
nature's bibliophiles as well so and
he's lucky with his teachers very lucky
with his teachers in Virginia and but I
think wanted to be private and we only
we know that his first date was a
nightmare with Miss Rebecca Burwell the
most sought-after
babe
of the town in those days and he he
worked out a very carefully pretty much
too carefully rehearsed approach to her
and a dance and was made to look and
feel I think a complete idiot
and wrote an agonized letter to a friend
the next day about this and started to
get his migraine attacks at that point
huh which never left him we've all been
there I'm gonna ask my last question to
allow the the audience their their
chance and that's going to be maybe an
inevitable question it's the mix of
lives that a biography represents that I
want to get at because how much you are
aware that it is
Korda on grant or how much Korda
withdraws either in the voice you use or
in the the aspiration toward objectivity
that you that you you planned so I'd
like each of you to just give some sense
of whether you're consciously holding
yourself back or enjoying what may in
fact be an essay by you on this life and
so you're part of it well you can't even
if you tried very hard you cannot remove
yourself the notion of a totally
objective biography is almost impossible
to achieve and probably not worth
achieving because you could do that
essentially by putting together just a
salient fact of a life in the form of a
list the Encyclopedia Britannica
provides pretty good objective
biographies of
almost anybody you can think of in there
quite concise but if you're going to
like somebody's life and really write it
you must bring to the table whether you
like them or not your own feelings about
that person about the world they lived
in about you yourself you cannot avoid
seeing them through your arms and but
what about your voice is it there well
your voice of course has to be there
because if you are a writer your voice
is what
you're the essential thing that you have
it also and it's one argument
another strong argument against
plagiarism as if they were not already
enough is that is that over the length
of the book it would be enormously
tedious to try and write about anything
in a voice or with a range of interests
that we're not your own
and so to attempt to do it that way
would be almost undoable I think for
most writers but above all I think the
the important thing is not to be
completely objective because you can't
pretend to be that but to be completely
open to the reality that's presented to
you on a page and you can't turn away
from the worst in your character you're
a central figure you mustn't exalt over
the best
you must try and present as nearly as
you can the person as you think that
person was now that's a difficult task
and a challenge and it's probably not
possible for any biographer even the
most gifted one to succeed in doing that
a hundred percent but that's what you
really have to do you have to read each
page and say if grant himself for
reading this page would he agree with it
but he disagree with it would he think
it was fair but do you think it was
unfair and those are questions which
ought to keep a biographer awake at
night to what extent is your book a
collaboration of two lives well I think
for one thing it's it's always a great
idea to have artists write about other
artists I mean there are things that
Caravaggio experienced and and faced in
the world that that I felt extremely
sympathetic toward I also felt just for
me that I was able to use the various
disparate and and often sort of
schizophrenic parts of my life as a
writer in the book I mean that is you
know my long career as a novelist my
briefer career as an
critic and and also you know insofar as
I write what I guess is called cultural
criticism I feel that that you know it's
the kind of voice crying out in the
wilderness against things that are
trashy and false and sentimental and
Hollow which was certainly what
Caravaggio was doing every moment mr.
what I like the question you asked
before what has an echo of it about
sympathy for once on my I just I just
voyage back to Oxford to attend the
retirement dinner of my old to history
tutor Brian Harrison who actually so far
from retiring has just given up his
college position to produce the general
edition of the dictionary of national
biography which I believe some of you
can already get online I mean it's about
to be anyway and it's by all accounts an
epic achievement of its kind
extraordinary thing the DMV hasn't been
redone for some time and Brian's really
done it every Vacanti hear of it is very
praising I mentioned this because his
practice has been as I think the DMV's
was for some time if you want to get
people who can really write about it
convincingly for others they probably
should have some sympathy for us what
are some knowledge of there's no bit
otherwise you wouldn't have all these
wonderful portraits of old Dean's and
bishops and figures of the Church of
England that are one of the delights of
the DMB and for example there's an eight
and a half thousand word entry on Karl
Marx in in the listener edition and it's
by Eric Hobsbawm who was been a
communist most of his life I would say I
wouldn't quarrel with that because there
actually isn't anyone who knows the
subject better than Hobbes born at least
if there is I can't think who it would
have been who could possibly be given
that job but since everyone knows who he
is
and since everyone knows as it were
where his heart and sleeve come into
opposition I think there's no harm in
that at all again my own case I claim is
different because in there are only
about three presidential studies I think
you could ride that me you you have to
write about the United States without
whom there wouldn't be a United States
there's obviously Washington clearly
Jefferson certainly Lincoln and probably
Roosevelt
without is possible without these it was
possible to imagine there not being the
United States as we understand it to be
so that's a lot to ask and one reason I
was so grateful to James and so humble
where I was trying to avoid using or
being for this was that it can happen to
coincide with my own decision to take
out the papers of citizenship of
American I decided sometime after
September 11th of 2001 that I'd be
treating the country of its views in a
way if I just went on being a green card
holder I wanted to make it plain that I
had signed on hmm and so it was in that
frame of mind that I wrote about
Jefferson I doesn't get made me any more
lenient about any of his shortcomings or
crimes it was said by some historian now
forgotten that this is about about a
century ago now I think that if
Jefferson was right the United States is
right if Jefferson was wrong the United
States is wrong too simple but worth
cogitating I'm glad you decide your
decision earlier than Henry James did
about Britain fears is that there's an
odd parallel well I make my students do
this about Eliot very nearly succeeded
in becoming an Englishman and orden
succeeding more or less in becoming a
New Yorker at least which culture got
the best of the bargain it's a good
essay I make them do with Henry James
unfortunately no question which
countries are the best ago now I'd like
to give the audience a chance at
questions we will we have about 10 10 15
minutes for that if you are interested
in asking this elegant Cruz something no
oh yes please would you stand up and as
loudly as you can mr. Corda I'm curious
if you said saw any affinity between
grant and
speak up yes any affinity whether you
saw any affinity between grant and Huck
Finn unhooked in yes that's an
interesting question actually and and
but it relates to the question which we
discussed of going back to the era in
which the person lived with some sense
of sympathy and understanding for that
period it's not accidental that Mark
Twain ended up being grants publisher
and it's not accidental that American
literature to some degree rests upon
grants extraordinary brevity and
lapidary ability to write concise
English his memoirs are an amazingly
readable an amazingly well-written book
but our lesson in how to write brief
short sentences from which Hemingway
Gertrude Stein and any number of
American writers who grew up in the
heartland derived their style you can
regress memoirs and see quite quickly
how anybody reading them would be led
towards a particularly abrupt and
compressed style of writing in addition
to which of course growing up in Ohio in
Illinois in the 1820s the 1830s
next to a great river because he was
born on the Ohio River Grant had what
looks superficially like a Huck Finn
childhood on the other hand when you
read about his father Jesse Grant who
was surely one of the most overbearing /
ambitious and bumptious people ever to
have fathered a child and his
extraordinary was thinking as a
politician yeah I know
competition but but in any such
competition trust genuine grant would
would get a strong number of votes um
you realize that it's a deceptive Huck
Finn childhood it's barefooted and
fishing with a bare hook in the Ohio
River and growing up in the
circumstances of Huck Finn but growing
up also under a shadow of expectations
he couldn't fulfill an awkwardness which
were the dog grant or his life but yeah
grants childhood looks on the surface a
lot like Huck Finn's interesting
question yes please and would you stand
thank you yes and I'd like you to if you
would talk about how you approach those
biographies baldie it brief and then I'd
like to ask your publisher which women
he is
the first question was to Francine about
the muses and and how that might relate
and then we'll get to the the second
well they were shorter the essays were
shorter for sir and also I was thinking
about them in relation to one another so
in other words my choice of which women
to put in the book depended a lot on
which other women I had in what sort of
stories I was telling I'm and I just
knew that I wanted nine stories as
different from one another as I possibly
could
I mean Caravaggio you know it was just
me and Caravaggio so it's a very
different situation and you know it
depended I mean that the nine women in
the book some of them I felt extremely
sympathetic toward and some of them
quite a bit less so a Caravaggio was it
was pure sympathy and the second part of
the question was really to James Atlas
and that was is it a mere coincidence
that all of these lives are lives of men
or is in fact are there a number of
lives of women I think that's
essentially what you were asking in the
series and James would you mind given
this awesome responsibility to stand so
everybody can can face
responsibilities and my previous series
we had today
go to hood immediately I think if I go
back up here anyway we had Joan of Arc
by Mary Gordon and we had Catherine
Harrison on sanctuary so these yeah
however I confess that we have I think
it's I confess that we have I've gotten
me up here again I confess that we have
had a problem in this area very little
of which can be attributed to my being
the male chauvinist if you look at
history and if you look at the history
of literature if you look at great
generals great religious figures
unfortunately men rule now that may
change
I assume it's going to change but anyone
who has suggestions come and see me
after the show
whatever we almost had a life of
Margaret Thatcher yeah we did but I
gotta say Jefferson's preferable okay
well fairly asked fairly answered
another question oh yes thanks again
would you stand up and boom out as you
can
this problem is a variation of the last
question you asked mr. Cushing about
imagination when you write history of
course you
hamster come on amount of imagination
but are you aware do you have some sort
of internal monitor that tells you a
certain point when you're when you're
laps into the area of speculation frenzy
or novice but that must be an
irresistible temptation especially they
don't have any source materials the word
lady
Christopher just the opposite because
you have so much too little interest
that is there a danger that you reach up
one where you know that you're only
speculating you've left your subject
behind it is that this is there
something you knew existed that's that's
what I can't
I would just summarize that it's
basically the question of the temptation
of over speculation
maybe the investment of yourself in this
without sufficient evidence and are you
aware and worried about that Michael
well you mentioned before David
McCullough and having been his editor
and publisher for a very long time David
once told me and I think it's absolutely
true that the words a biographer must
shy away from as if they were totally
evil or he must have felt so that when
you read a biography of Napoleon that
says as he crossed the Neman River
Napoleon
must have felt you should put the book
down and move on to another book at any
rate you should begin to approach the
book with great great caution we know
what people did we know what they said
we know what they wrote we do not know
how they must have felt and therefore
all of us the Barger is a Napoleon in
which there's at least as much fact
available as on Thomas Jefferson if not
more I nevertheless they will inevitably
bring you to what must he have felt as
he stepped upon the decks of the
Bellerophon well we don't know what he
felt when he stepped upon the decks
eternal era for and therefore as
biographers we have to be very careful
whenever we find ourselves typing those
particular words to ask do we in fact
know and if we don't take them out
anyone else on the temptations of
speculation I would just add the phrase
would have thought yes yes no I would
say must have filled it must be in there
somewhere I'll tell you why when I said
earlier that I can't believe there's
ever been an argument about Sally
Hemings I mean that you can make it come
out differently
you can even have Jefferson alone in
Paris a widower and you can have him
asked for one servant to be sent with
his daughter and get another one he
didn't know was coming who's just turned
15 and is his wife's half-sister and
looks like him it's like her and you can
read the letters that he writes to other
women that contain dick jokes penis
jokes taken from Lawrence Stern and so
on and you can you can look at all that
and see what I bet he never laid a glove
on her if you like if you don't make the
assumption that some people don't if he
was some kind of I think it's cherubim
and Seraphim and it forbidden to have
genitalia and even in their mythological
appearance well if you don't think he
did then you don't know what he must
have felt but if you do think he did
then you do know what he must have felt
if there isn't a full response he must
have looked at her and thought all my
birthday's have just arrived in Paris at
once yeah that's what he must have
thought I can be confident on it it
would be nice to have a picture of her I
must say it would be it would be really
good to have it even a painting we don't
have a thing but we have some very good
descriptions he must have felt wow we
have time for one question more that may
have neatly summed it up
okay oh yes please and again
Stan just repeat the question have you
considered a writing about a person who
or have you done a person who is still
living I have written about people who
are still living yes and and it's a lot
easier to write about people who are
dead I I wrote about my aunt merle
oberon while she was still alive
and and had caused to deeply regret
having done so I think it's terrific to
write about people were still living but
it's very difficult to write about them
with total honesty and the one thing to
be said for biography is there are an
awful lot of interesting dead people to
write about you'd have to be willing to
take very serious risks indeed if you
were to write honestly about living
people there's a chapter on Yoko Ono and
another one on Suzanne Farrell and I
spent a lot of time on the phone with
the HarperCollins lawyers almost as much
time talking to the lawyers as I did
writing the chapters so that's a it was
a cautionary experience for me the
lawyers to I've written it would be it
would be a very client friend of mine
who would call either these stretch here
but they were intended as polemical
revisions of existing reputations one
case of William Jefferson Clinton and in
the other case of mr. cause Henry
Kissinger and the purpose of the two
books was in the first case just trying
to shorten the political career and in
the second case of possible to try
shorten the life okay breathing either
biography of starbella was still alive
yes don't do it well I think on that
note wonderful that you had the last
word let's think both our panelists and
our shadow panelists